Hey, it’s Evan.
Today I’m answering a question from one of my
YouTube viewers Tori who commented on my Evernote Tutorial
“Best Evernote tutorial I have found
Thank you. (Thank you so much Tori for the kind words)
Any suggestions for (Middle School or High School)
students on organizing sections and tabs?”
This is such a great question.
Evernote was not around when I was in high school.
I kind of wish it was
How I would do it is, so if I’m here, I’m at my Notebooks,
I would look at creating a new Notebook for each class that I’m taking
and then a new Note for every individual class
every individual topic within that class.
Here’s how I’d do it.
If I was doing it I would go to my Notebooks
of course I’ve got all of this other stuff happening in my life
so I’d create a special stack just for it.
You can’t start with a stack right away
so you start with a Notebook.
I would say, maybe call this History.
So this is my Notebook.
I would right click on that and go Add to stack
create a new stack
and I would call my new stack
School
and then I could go down to school
and I would create a new Notebook
for every subject that I wanted to create notes on.
So that could be, you know, however many subjects students are taking.
Within my History one
so if I’m going to history class every day
or every second day
whatever it is, I’d create a new Note for every class
or every main topic within that History class.
So I remember when I was in high school
I used to take notes with a pen and paper.
I didn’t even have a laptop in my high school.
Pen and paper, and at the top of every page what I would write is the date.
So you just start a new page
so I do the same thing in Evernote
and I would call it Nov 22
(and whatever we’re learning, maybe it’s talking about the)
War of 1812 and then start typing all my notes.
And I’d have everything I need here
about the War of 1812 that I’ve learned in that class
then maybe, next week I’d come to the class
and we’re talking about something else.
I would call that Nov 29
– (and we’re learning about) World War II
and take all my notes and put that in there.
And then whenever I need to review my notes
I could quickly find anything I need either by date
by topic, or I could do a full text search
and find anything that I wrote about.
So that’s how I do it.
Again, I’m creating a stack that I call School
I’m creating Notebooks for every subject that I’m taking
and then I’m creating every note
New Notes for every day of the class
and every new piece of information that’s coming
through me at that class.
So again, I wish I had this in high school.
Would’ve been a lot easier to keep track of my notes
and find the stuff I was looking for.
But that’s how I’d use it.
Great question.
If you have any other thoughts on this
another question, I can answer for you.
Please feel free to leave it in the comments below.
If you guys liked the video, give it a thumbs-up.
But I really do want to hear from you.
Let me know what you think. Leave a comment.
If you have a question about Evernote
and how to use it I’d be happy to make a video response.
Thank you so much and I’ll see you soon.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community